okay now hi hi how do i invite people
oh gosh i'm like a middle-aged woman who
needs tech support alone in my kitchen
how does one
contact people i might be back on am i
back on sid
okay ross wherever you are oh i see
kelly jean smith
oh i see why everybody's so into these
these are so cool oh wow someone has a
very
naughty name dirt mother how did you
even get away with that name
good for you for getting away with it i
hope ross
calls me hello ross i'm here oh thank
god i suck at this so bad i never do ig
lives
okay let me tell you thank god they
don't give emmys for instagram lives
because we would not get nominated
oh my god i would only get a raspberry
well and if there's ever a day to go
live to today is the day can i just can
i just say
drew you the show got nominated for
three
emmy awards daytime emmy awards and you
drew are nominated for best
talk show host okay i need to know
everything where were you when you found
out
how did it go down what happened
see you're the best journalist that's
why i love being in a new
video and the rest of the show better do
in life and friendship
okay so when i step out energy tonight
our
um sister sibling show announced only
two calories
and one was the actress in a drama
and then the other was a taco host
and i found out last night from them
like that happened and
i was with my two daughters we were
alone in our kitchen
and they were all playing stickers
so like eight nine at night like too
late for them to be up but you know
we're just
you know rocking and rolling us three
little sardines in our camp
and i looked up and i was like girls i
can't even believe this i
never want to be indulgent i'm so not
that mom like girl
look like i was like
do you do you know like award shows like
like for movies there's like
and they're like yeah the academy awards
and i was like and for television they
were like there's the emmys and i was
like you guys are so
savvy that's so cool i know
my my i'm so so impressed with their
knowledge and i was like i just got
nominated for an
emmy and they were like frankie looked
at me like this
like she had this like
that was her expression all of like got
up
and like embraced me and that's so not
olive all is a very cool customer
um and it was just a light like
and then we just sat back down and went
back to the stickers and
that was it was perfect they were the
two people
i want to be the proudest or tell them
the most
so i got to but then
i my joy completely started to
close in on itself because i cared about
the show
and i felt like so
excited but for me you know how much i
don't say it's my show it's i
it's never i it's we it's ours it's the
show
it's the show um has my name on it to
function but it's the show
yeah it's ours all of ours it's all of
ours and we asked everyone to do this
show at this unprecedented time and the
world was a scary place and it was a
scary place to try it
and everybody was working from remote
and shows weren't being done that way
and we were trying to create new
technology
and like build big screens and dream up
this thing and
they get gave us the chance to do it
not knowing what it was but all of these
people came together and they like held
hands and they closed their eyes
someone had said like what is the show
what does it look like we had to come up
with all of that together
what angles will we take what stories
are we telling what
pillars will we have what will it look
like like how will it function
raise the bar in technology we will
purpose a gift
and to me it's the validation of every
single person
who was able to get to know each other
virtually and become real friends and
then jason
our executive producer he always says
you know on a weekend go live your life
and bring it back to the show
and i wanted to do everyone to be
themselves
that with people this show is a part of
every single person
who built it and so we really
needed which means you got nominated to
rossi ross can i tell you
where i was when we got that when i got
the news that the show was nominated
please do so i just gone to homegoods
i'm a baller and then i was leaving
fergus
and i got a text on my phone and i had
to pull over and i facetimed
chris the producer your friend just like
and then sammy sullivan producer and i
were texting everyone's so
excited do you make the show feel like
really like a family and so we all are
so invested
and you know this year was tough and we
made it up
you led the team making up as we went
along
and it worked and
it just felt so good it has all the
feels and
speaking of all uh our whole crew
our entire team like all hundred and
whatever we are um
got on our zoom and we used to start the
show that way so we're all familiar with
it and then once we got shooting it's
how we launched the show
all of us um in pods on zooms but then a
lot of the entire groups so that
everyone could hear
the same thing at the same time because
we were
flying blind so we had to build the
vision together
and um we were all separated so we had
to
you know and i'm just i'm so impressed
with everyone
and this is such a lovely day and i'm
not good at celebrating i'm usually like
what can i do better next and
i go into a whole like self-improvement
spiral when these things happen so
i wanted to talk to the crew
and family and team and then i thought
it would be fun to do an ig live with
you
um like well by the way this should be
the first of many
um right dude i'll do this with you
my first one went so well
for sure i should live in this space
uh regularly you're a natural um
i really i mean i i was just so excited
for you and
um you know i remember when i was like
watching the enemies
and and you know dreaming of that world
and
to be a part of that now it was like so
incredible
a few milestones um i'm just so excited
and you know i'm just i'm sitting in my
new place here in palm springs i know
p.s i love you
i'm so like just a blank wall but i just
stopped unpacking
and sat down and i'm like just so
thrilled i
ig bombed you yes
and um yeah
this is an absolutely lovely and special
day and
i want to say this if i may um
when i moved out on my own when i was 14
years old it was
hella intimidating and i had this tv
and i actually have one in my kitchen
right now there's my little
white tv yes it's usually on
um but on turner classic movies and
i had this tv in my kitchen when i was
14 years old and it was
i was never scared because i knew the
emergency broadcasting
would come in and tell me like
it was going down and
so i knew when that wasn't happening it
was safe and i
found the shows to be like my roommates
and they kept me company and i think
that
television is such a powerful thing we
are entertained by it we're educated by
it
we're inspired by it we escape oh my god
who doesn't want to get home from work
and grab that remote control
my number one yeah and to be a part of
television is such a is the biggest
gift it has done so much for me in my
life
and been such an an extraordinary poetic
companion to me so i feel so lucky
that we're getting to work no on
broadcast television right now as the
world goes digital and platforms and the
game is changing
that's why we have to constantly be
thinking about all platforms and
360 because everybody is experiencing
things differently
um yet how do we bring us all together i
knew i didn't want to be anyone else
right now in my life because of my kids
um although getting to do sheila hammond
on santa clarita diet
was a reminder that i have
this skill set inside of me that loves
to
act and have an excuse to be that crazy
because we all feel that way inside
like i want to be fire starter i want to
be a charlie's angels i want to be
sheila hammond i want to
eat your face off because you're pissing
me off yeah
like we all have those moments so to
live through characters and do
things that i could never do in my real
life
has been my journey thus far but ever
since i had kids i've been struggling
with that i want to be me i'm not
as into the fantasy i'm too obsessed
with the reality
yeah yeah i see that and it's got to be
would it scary at first to do that to
like come out on the show and just
be you i know that sounds so weird but
when that
camera's on and it's live and you're
doing it it's risky
um you know it was hard
to go out and try and make jokes with
nobody laughing
right i know
you just make it safe and you build
people around you and you
believe in the moment you're like i'm so
transcended when i'm on that set i i
i feel very connected to all of it not
like the ig world where i'm like what is
this but i like that
yeah i know um so i'm a storyteller
i want to tell the story you and i give
information
our show as news um human interest
you know design food
uh field pieces uh i wanted to
tackle a lot of the things we're all
very interested in and not just be one
thing
has to be good conversations but a lot
of stuff around it
and comedy and i went hard on comedy
when we launched
and it was september in 2020 the
craziest time
ever and it felt really scary to do that
i tried to
you know we were doing the show live so
that i could pivot moment to moment and
be completely accurate on everything was
changing minute to minute
it was everything at stake in the world
so i wanted to start off incredibly
respectful and greet each morning live
so i made sure i didn't make a misstep
to respect the world
so what do we have coming up i mean
what's season two look like season one
was unprecedented historic
right no one's ever done that launched a
show in something like that
so where do you go from here um okay so
we're
today we looked at incredible renderings
with tom and mel who built our set who
were like
i worked with them scrupulously on every
detail and i really love our world the
home show really inspired me to like
want to get people out of their homes
and build them a world they could be in
um so we just did the other half of the
studio where it's been empty and it's
all audience
it's so exciting oh my gosh
you have no idea anyone who may be here
you you're literally like you're joe
cartman
i saw i just saw her oh god i wish we
could bring her into this she's at the
news desk with us
yeah there's a guy named bones matthews
by the way that just that's my brother
shut up where oh my god yeah
bye aaron well see i forget to look down
i don't know where i'm looking again
this is all new to me
um but um i don't even remember what we
were talking about
season two in the audience yes yes we're
gonna have an audience
you know it's such a different we have
had so much fun on the show and the crew
has become our audience you know and
they're around
we know we're talking to everybody at
home as well but to have people live
there that energy where we can feel it
it's such a game changer
it it'll be so appreciated because
we did not have the benefit of that in
season one
and when we launched the world was
really scary and
we didn't know to make a lot of noise or
laugh it
you know it was it was tense beyond
tense
um so yeah everyone really banded
together with a few people who were on
the floor
and we tried to create the noise and the
energy together and so
i'll never want to lose sight of that
time because it'll never be that
intimate again
exactly for season two you know i'm not
assuming we're getting a season three i
don't assume anything
i just keep my head down and do the work
and i'm so honored to get to do this
again
take it higher take it bigger um i
appreciate
by the way all the people like who got
nominated
sean evans i got to be nominated in a
category with sean evans
he is one of my favorite journalists and
i'm actually going to release on my
instagram
a clip from our art of the interview
that i did with him before we launched
the show and he's been at the desk with
us didn't we
yeah yeah
um i love sean so much and i got
nominated with him and to me i was like
really that is so cool
he's rad he has super integrity and he
built a
juggernaut from a simple concept that
works so
chef's his perfectly and he the clip i'm
going to show is he talks about his
integrity of research and like why he
has it and how it
what happened in his life that made him
that way um and
people just want to see things different
so i hope we can keep
being ourselves keep growing and keep
coming up with
you know fun things for people
like just fun
joy goodness awareness optimism
interesting point of view right
design food inspiration information
um i'm so excited to be in this garden
and keep growing with you
this was such a cool way for me to
celebrate it
i'm so proud to be on the journey with
you drew
thank you and congratulations from all
of us
and to the entire team thank you
congratulations to you and the whole
show because
the fact that they're nominated is what
makes the most sense to me
and um everybody who joined us i'm sorry
i suck at this
i get better this is just
not sit well with me believe me i'm
going to be like
get your [ __ ] together we'll do
duplicates next time
yeah um but i had a lot of fun and
um thank you so much for anyone who was
like
all right i guess you know i'll watch
this giggle fest
um i love you russian i love you drew
congrats to everyone congratulations
right back at you
and thanks for joining us anyone and
everyone
bye do you know how to hang out
[Laughter]
i think i figured it out ready okay
three two
[Music]
three